Heather asks Gary I've watched every ass
oh but guys outnumber women do you see
women and men differ on success and
tactics Heather a great point someone we
need more women questions but you can
only do what you got I mean the truth is
you know now they're losing some weight
maybe we'll get some more female fans
but the fact that matter is I really
think that I need more female pants no I
think I think that um I think that
there's absolutely no it's crazy it's so
funny how I think about business I don't
care if you're a corkscrew if you've got
the guts if you've got the juice if
you've got the ability I'm super
interested I don't I don't see you know
we're probably a 60/40 female company um
and we're probably more crowding what
are we 63
so we're 63% female driven company and
on the upper scour executive creative
director the woman that runs our San
Francisco office up until last week are
literally my right hand managing
director I mean I don't see any real
difference up one I'm not looking for
any real difference but I don't see a
huge difference of how you know a male
or a female view successor or acting I
mean within them their differences right
I mean I don't think that I don't yeah
you look nobody's confused that we're
wired differently but I haven't really
noticed it